what up friends it's the weekend which
means we try to do some family stuff on
the weekend Bart is in California right
now I feel like all my Vlogs are that
way but it just so happens to be
coincidental every time I'm Vlogging but
um taika
it's past the F out
we came out to I don't know what city
I'm in in Las Vegas
um and uh we're out here to attend the
Great American foodie Fest and let me
just show you there's like a bunch of
like
blown out hold up
there we go wow what a reveal right
but yeah so it's like a little Carnival
um but there's gonna be a bunch the
emphasis on this one is obviously oh my
God Geo
I'm a [ __ ] show
oh my God
the emphasis on this is gonna be food
it's gonna be in the 90s today but it is
Vegas it's dry so it'll probably feel
like
California 80s
more or less uh so I'm not too worried
about the heat as much somebody bought
an umbrella I have a hat same same yeah
just gonna wait for this dude to wake up
to see what we do first
um I think we got here really early
because there's like
maybe about 100 cars and it looks like
this log could fit like 5 000 if not 10
000 cars I'm also really bad at
perceiving
amounts of numbers like that so
I mean it just it's like a big ass lot
look at that
yeah and I'm like it's all over
there's only one two three four I'm in
the fifth row so there's only six rows
of cars right now
you throw okay I'm gonna do the math
what the [ __ ] I think I'm just killing
time
this dude is out should I wake him up
anyway in the meantime
I don't wear hats because I don't think
I look good in them and this hair just
makes me look
funny in it
right okay well anyway how are you I
hope you're doing well
today's a beautiful day
we're awake I have air in our lungs
and we have the power to change this day
to whatever the [ __ ] we want it to be so
if you're having a shitty ass day and
you don't believe that you have the
power to change it
try to put that shitty ass day and flip
it and turn it on its head and just say
you know what [ __ ] it I'm gonna make it
a good day
and then just make it a good day even if
you have to lie to yourself to make it a
good day
just be like it's a [ __ ] good day you
just [ __ ] crash your car good
it's a [ __ ] good day at least I'm
still alive and see if you're if your
day changes I guarantee it's gonna
change power of the Mind
should I wake him up
nah
okay so I woke him up
good morning
what's on your neck
you ready to party
let's go hooty hoos
let's go hoodie who who's
so we are inside and the first thing
tiger wants to do is what
what's the first thing you want to do
thank you
got this oh boy
oh yeah
[Music]
all right let's do it let's see
monkey do you know where you're going
you gotta figure out how to get in it's
a maze
[Music]
wait wait for me you're stuck
oh
hey we're back here
[Applause]
we're stuck
[Music]
don't hit it okay where do we go
do you want to go ahead let him go first
monkey
all right let's go
you go your way
okay you go your way
oh good job
hey you did it
hey look look come here look at the
mirror
whoa
no come here look at this mirror monkey
come here
okay you're gonna go
whoa
go for it dude
go
foreign
do I have to go too
oh [ __ ]
all right I guess we all have to go down
let's see oh my God this is for sure
babe we're little kids but we're doing
this [ __ ]
here we go again okay go
that way yeah there you go
whoa whoa whoa whoa
he definitely ran into one of the beer
and stuff and it didn't catch it
yeah oh there he is
yeah I'm over here go
oh
you want to get on the ferris wheel
or wait no that's not a fair so what is
this called right here right here
let's see how tall you are
how many inches
you're 45 inches tall why not yeah not
yet we gotta wait for her to
let us in I think
yeah
I think she's helping everyone else whoa
we gotta get on the cars after okay you
wanna do that one
are you thinking about that one she's
coming back
all right monkey are you ready are you
gonna cry
are you gonna feel scared hey the you're
on number three that's my favorite
number do you know that
right there right here
number three that's my favorite number
huh
it is with the baby oh wow oh okay
you ready to rock and roll he's about to
start it
let's go
see you later
whoa hold on tight I don't want you to
fall out
hey
so it's like a good on four rides now
we're just gonna get a little snack okay
he says three
[Music]
um and now I just want to check out what
food they got you want don't kick the
dirt dude those are your school shoes
whoa look at this
holy okay let's glue that next one let's
look at our options what's the next one
okay there's lemonade there
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
huh
[Music]
what's this
this one is so tiger was craving uh
lemonade so we're here at Twisted lemon
monkey what flavor did you get
um foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's hot home
yeah go ahead okay get some of the dumps
that means the dumps are good
look at your shoes oh my God okay
go eat some of the dumps oh come on
I feel like that's gonna fall
[Music]
if it falls leave it alone who told you
that
go
wait for me monkey
foreign
we are back home now holy Crap took a
nap it was so hot outside wasn't it dude
okay so we took a nap we're home now
Tycho wants to do something what are we
doing
[Music]
um so we have
show me the balls look at all this stuff
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
show me an example
nope it's pretty dark in there
yeah
oh yeah get a little shark
kill a hat now put it put the light
inside the thing yeah like that okay
already already what are we doing
[Applause]
hey you know what you're definitely bar
Kwan's son you know why
you know why
because that the what you're wearing is
what barquan wears all the time
you're a little chony boy just like your
papa
ready
show me an example you go first I'm
gonna record you
okay what's the goal we gotta make it in
the
in the okay got it
okay cool
okay
here let me put it there
go
so close so close
oh
so close
ow that was my hand
s
man I'm the worst there we go
knock it down another one
oh he made it baby
you just hit your tummy tummy
okay my turn right yes your turn my turn
[Applause]
um
[Music]
balls for sure balls
how many chances do I get three yeah no
one one chance only yeah and if I make
it you get you go again okay here we go
look
I was pretty sure I was gonna happen
okay
[Music]
um bugs okay balls
whoa which one do you want me to explain
whatever you want I want to see your
puppies
that looks like it's not gonna make the
bucket because it's so heavy I wouldn't
do that shark shark
actually this is really heavy to throw
don't throw the shark it's metal it's
die cast metal do uh
do uh scorpion
yeah Advanced okay I wanna make it
oh he's gonna pinch you if you don't
make it
go
okay my turn wow
but if I make it you have to eat this
bowl
ready
oh you got so lucky
[Applause]
[Music]
we're all these different things coming
from
[Applause]
that's not fair
head first monkey head first
yep all right monkey what's it 25 or six
you said 25. but this one's not the same
size as that one so what are we gonna
make right now
um
oh yeah so you got the large
marshmallows
but we ran out
of something that's kidney yeah and then
the recipe calls for 40 large but we
only have how many did you count
um in there how much you count
I'm 36. 25. you're 26 I count you want
to count again
go one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen
okay and then this is the other half so
we're just gonna mix it all up right so
then we got our
s we got our butter
and then we got our six cups of rice
krispies sorayao
so the first thing we're gonna do monkey
eat some beefy sure and then after we do
that the three cups of butter we're
gonna melt it okay
and once the cups once the Butter's
melted are you listening to me yeah
okay then we're gonna melt the
marshmallows
then once the marshmallows are done then
what do we put in
nope oh we can add chocolates if you
want
old dude on half I don't really like
chocolate and then we're gonna throw in
some rice recipes
a little bark Quan
okay let's get started yes Quinn
so monkey
yeah what is this
um
who made it
all by myself oh buyer are you sure
about that nobody helped you
are you sure
um okay I feel dissed sure
monkey
try to talk to him about not talking
about private parts because they're not
a joke
even though he's gonna come to realize
when it gets older that it really is but
not right now live but yeah we made it I
mean taika made it all by himself
look what the Cat Dragged In Every
kidney Papa's back in town yeah that
guy's out
I like that he's in his PJs yeah so
comfy okay I'm gonna kiss you now kiss
me
just got home and already snack and I
thought you were cutting dude I actually
lost a pound this week or no three
pounds but pretty good right wow man I
gained a ton yeah oh for sure I'm for
sure fluffy because I'm actually I'm
actually uh what's it called
Massey no bulking but there's another
term
I don't know okay well yes I'm I'm
bulking but I'm doing a clean bulk I'm
not doing like [ __ ] go off the rails
and eat everything like what I did and I
gave my 30 pounds do your whole life you
did your whole life no I'm actually just
doing high protein high carb
um just regular average fats
um and so like a lot of the food that
I'm still eating is very diet so I'm
like eating uh super lean beef and like
protein and stuff I have a lot of higher
carbs yeah like I meal prep literally
everything you actually get really smart
I see uh what you're doing with the
multiple protein sources yeah so when
you need to use pot of pizza there it is
yeah and I got my veggies because that's
also recommended and I'm like making
some veggies as we speak I got some
veggies right here too
Tyga made it I know it's CUNY and he
didn't want to eat it he's like you he
likes cooking but he doesn't like
tasting it I like all of the activities
that you and him do the best yeah we had
so much fun today
we went to um this food fair yeah it's
called the um Great American food uh
commercial or something popped up maybe
an ad on Instagram or something yeah so
I took him and then the rides are like
your typical carnival rides and like
they're [ __ ] they're just they're just
Shady like it's just they look sketches
fun
um but he wanted to get on them and like
they start right so as soon as the like
he'll get like a little motorcycle and
as soon as they Press Start you see his
head going oh [ __ ] because it's just so
rough yeah yeah and like it's just so
jarring and like it just moves them so
much like all the kids were crying he'd
be like I'm scared
and then he starts laughing but uh he
did like the fun house maze one
and you just seem [ __ ] slam into
because you know how they're all glass
those mazes kind of like um
yeah what's it called
no Bruce Lee entered the dragon with the
house of mirrors it was like that so
type was going like this and one he was
confident that he didn't need it so he
walked me it was so good
yeah
thanks dude wait what the [ __ ] you're
eating that vegetable and that no don't
eat that first because that's gonna kill
that flavor because that's barely
anything